peu
[Musique]
il
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
merci bernard
[Musique]
et
bonjour nous avons voulu cette semaine
donner la parole à une minorité agréable
et intéressante
les poules piste monsieur cory zier
bonjour messieurs corrosives ou êtes
depuis 1975 président des poules piste
de france 76 précisément oui et alors
quel est le but de votre association
c'est une excellente question je vous
remercie de me l'avoir posée la pf c'est
à dire l'association des bouddhistes de
france a été créé dans le but de mettre
en contact et de faire se rencontrer
aussi souvent que faire se peut les
françaises et les français qui aiment à
se mettre un poulpe sur la tête
voilà et comment devient ampoules piste
excellente question on devient poule
piste on devient pour le pis pas par
besoin d'identité par besoin de se
reconnaître soi même par besoin de se
reconnaître pour lutter contre cette
société et robotisée c'est cela le
moulin blanc et poule pis par besoin de
ce rock nous est alors en dehors de ce
facteur de reconnaissance quels sont les
autres avantages du poulpe isme c'est
une excellente question ils sont
vraiment multiples voyez-vous par
exemple l'été le poulpe est frais et
très agréable à porter en revanche
l'hiver il constitue un rempart très
très efficace contre toutes les
intempéries le froid la neige et puis
par ailleurs grâce à sa durance naturel
le poulpe retient les pellicules les
pellicules disgracieuses dans la
prolifération sauvage pourrait nuire par
exemple au développement d'une idylle
mais on dit aussi que le poulpe isma des
effets bénéfiques sur la santé alors
qu'en est il exactement c'est une
excellente question je vous remercie de
me l'avoir posée c'est tout à fait exact
vous faites allusion j'imagine l'action
analgésiques du pool pis manqua de
céphalées oui oui
alors si permis
les gens qui nous regardent ce soir
certains souffrent de maux de tête aux
migraines diverses qu'ils fassent
l'expérience suivante alors vous mettez
un poulpe sur la tête et vous absorbez
vous avez les deux aspirines et vous
verrez le résultat tout à fait
stupéfiant alors que si vous faites le
contraire
le résultat est nul et puis alors enfin
le bullpen paul piste constituer un
excellent remède facile contre le bruit
voyez vice-président et alors vous aussi
madame vous êtes poule piste depuis
toujours ou là là non vous allez rire
mais jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans j'étais
végétarienne authentique
puis j'ai rencontré georges l'un des
pionniers du pool piste et il vous a
converti non non il m'a toujours laissé
libre de mes opinions
sa maman lorsque nous allions au cinéma
ou bien au restaurant ou simplement
quand nous étions invités chez des amis
j'avais l'impression qu'il était un peu
triste d'être le seul apporter un plus
sur la tête
et puis l'idée que le jour du mariage
puisse arriver tête nue je crois qu'il
avait un petit peu honte de moi j'ai
cédé et vous ne le regrettez pas c'est
une excellente question je vous remercie
de leur poser je vais vous dire je ne
pourrais même pas supporter l'idée que
je puisse vivre sans un poulpe sur la
tête
mais quelle explication donnez-vous à
cela mais c'est un animal très
affectueux on s'y attache terriblement
très affectueux et très obéissants
regard des sultans pas bougé
ah oui non c'est impressionnant
[Musique]
doucement sultan doucement voilà d'abord
des animaux d'où une association
paisible et pourtant les poules piste
dérange puisqu'on continue à leur
refuser l'entrée des plages alors à ce
propos écoutons ce qu'a à dire la
présidente des noms poule piste de
france nous disons que le spectacle de
ces personnes qui se promènent sur nos
plages le tout le pas l'air est un
spectacle révoltant pour nos enfants et
même pour les adultes
en conséquence de quoi nous demandons
aux municipalités du littoral de france
de bien vouloir nous montrer ce qu'elles
ont dans leur pantalon en leur
interdisant les bords de mer vous
comprenez pourquoi
devant cette intolérance qui frise
l'apartheid nous demandons nous
demandons quoi nous demandons instamment
aux pouvoirs publics de nous réserver
des espaces où nous pourrons enfin nous
et battre et poulpe est librement parce
que c'est un droit
et parce que nous l'exigeons ça le
mélodieux c'est un excellent paultes je
vous remercie de m'avoir posé et bien
nous espérons que votre appel sera
entendu
la semaine prochaine nous vous parlerons
d'une autre minorité agréable et
intéressante
les rhinos et rocistes à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
un bon soir et maintenant jocelyne et
son équipe ont testé pour vous le test
c'est faux la nouvelle bouillabaisse
fils au volet tu fais bon fait bon mais
il vaut mieux réserver avant de l'amour
en fuite
j'ai testé pour vous le premier rasoir
jetable avant usage
moi je veux bien j'ai testé pour vous le
lions du zoo de vincennes
c'est un mal
[Musique]
eh bien oui christian ici jean-jacques
flatte ou là qui vous parle en direct de
bruxelles
je me trouve précisément devant le
palais de l'europe où nous attendons
tous sous une petite pluie fine mais
pénétrante la sortie des ministres du
marché commun agricole qui sont réunis
tous ici depuis maintenant trois jours
vous le savez pour tenter ensemble de
sortir l'europe agricole de l'impasse
dans laquelle se trouve actuellement
mais à l'heure où je vous parle on me
fait signe et on me fait signe que l'un
des délégués
oui je crois que c'est l'un des délégués
du marché comme agricole qui va sortir
oui c'est même le délégué français c'est
le délégué français c'est le délégué
français c'est monsieur que lamont
collard qui sort matin qui se présente
ce devant le sur le perron de du marché
du ministre monsieur les micros c'est là
c'est non parce que d'habitude je fais
le nom au mesdames messieurs après un
déjeuner de travail extrêmement positif
avec mes collègues de l'europe dé 6,9
9 oui c'est très simple capitulons il y
avait là roberto hands
car stand by halle safri 4 oui john
rollins a fait six autos et moi ça fait
neuf nouveaux l'homme aurait déjà et de
travail extrêmement positif avec mes
collègues de l'europe des neuf déjeuner
de travail qui a duré plus de cinq
heures et demi et qui est d'ailleurs un
des plus réussis que nous ayons fait
depuis six ans eh bien je suis en mesure
de vous dire aujourd'hui que tous les
problèmes de l'europe qu'ils soient
alimentaires agricoles vinicole ou
encore ceux du vin sans oublier ceux des
liqueurs et de ce qu'on nomme à tort le
pinard ont été abordés je tiens à redire
à tous et pessimistes voyaient l'europe
agonisante bois remorque et bien je leur
dis et le redis elle est repartie
l'europe comme en 40 vous avez abordé le
problème des laitages hollande et moi
qu'il est bien parce qu' est-ce que vous
avez abordé le problème des laitages
l'on dit oui oui ça ils ont été évoqués
durant ce déjeuner de travail
je crois que cette fois monsieur van
houtte hervé qu'a compris la mimolette
ne passera pas moi j'ai repris 4 fois du
camembert ans le machin avec du beurre
breton et ça ne nous a pas impressionné
outre mesure que monsieur van houtte
ehrbeck pour se venger et but avec le
ministre danois de bouteille de schnaps
car la belgique bien l'angle l'allemagne
et moi même avons immédiatement répliqué
en vidant neuf bouteilles de pommard
rétablissant ainsi l' équilibre vital au
sein de la communauté monsieur ministre
le problème des hormones dans la
volaille anglaise anglaise oui c'est là
écoutez alors ça je ne pas vous dire
parce que personne n'en a pris 1 lorsque
le poulet au porridge est arrivé là tout
le monde rien que la sauce déjà ça avait
l'air pire que les hormones yakin le
ministre allemand qui a eu le courage de
prendre une cuisse wiki ministre après
non non très sincèrement il s'est
contenté de recracher en proposant que
la grande bretagne soit issu du marché
commun vous aborder des problèmes de
limites de pêche 2 et qui les limite de
la pêche au quai pour la langoustine
monsieur noah et de marionnettes avec
écouter non sans julien n'avait pas
emmené je ne peux pas vous dire et la
viande à écouter alors ça je tiens à le
répéter encore une fois j'espère que ce
sera la dernière il n'y a aucun problème
de viol dans le marché comment écouter
lorsqu'on mange avec un bon appétit et
un bon coup du rhône qui peut me dire la
différence qu'il ya entre un mouton
anglais une vache allemande ou encore
italiens qui sinon ceux qui veulent
casserait l'europe
or en jouant la carte de la différence
écoutez nous étions là neuf ministres et
je vous rappelle que nous sommes des
ministres spécialistes nous étions là
neuf ministres et bien nous avons
dégusté les viandes
aucun de nous n'a pu dire ni de quel
pays il de quel animal
cette viande provenait et tout ça
pourquoi parce que nous voulons une
europe égale pour tous même pour les
animaux
et pour les animaux aussi
aulas pense à une très bonne proposition
du ministre au luxe travaux revoit qui
s'est tellement régalé avec le curry
d'agneau qui il a proposé que l'a
proposé que l'aisne entre-temps le
marché commun ce à quoi nous avons tous
dit d'accord à gauche
y'a pas longtemps à la condition que
l'on supprime les crédits pour la
culture des choux de bruxelles qu'on a
tous trouvé mais qu'on a mangé quand
même égaré par politesse et de politesse
aider florence dans la ville ou dans
laquelle on se trouve à bruxelles
à bruxelles vont écouter madame monsieur
il est maintenant au moins
20h30 et je crois que je vais devoir
vous quitter car nous avons ce soir à
dîner de travail très important car je
vous rappelle que le très grave problème
du coupage des vins italiens et français
n'a pas encore été résolu
cela risque de nous emmener très tard
dans la nuit
on y passera le temps qu'il faudra mais
on y arrivera monsieur milices et par
action de la suisse si vous faites
rentrer là dedans le marché commun est
ce que vous craignez pas que la suisse
après ce qui s'est passé mais nous
accorder bien ne puisse pas et pour qui
capable
ce mini c'est ce que vous pensez
direction de l'est de l'inde si jamais
encore au au cas où l'un d'entre eux à
grammont no mercy commun pensez vous que
les réactions des suisses razzano faible
comme d'habitude ou plus que les
messieurs après un déjeuner de travail
extrêmement positif déjeuner de travail
qui a duré plus de cinq heures et demie
ra n'ai plus réussi que nous ayons fait
depuis six ans eh bien je suis en mesure
de vous dire non et non tous les
problèmes de l'europe ils soient
alimentaires unique pulp ou ou un même
morceau du vin ou par le pinard
d'épinards
et pensez vous que pensez vous que la
suisse réagir à bien entrer dans le
marché commun
la dette explose
ils ont exclu lundi de l'inde
wii party l'un d'eux par combien
convient de tout réseau o2
c'était très dur parce que à la mi temps
j'avais beau bah non si on avait fait
qui s'est fait
c'est un carton rouge de l'équipe de
lundi
bonsoir cette semaine
h comme hésitation tout
[Musique]
on
et
j'ai testé pour vous l'annuaire du
lot-et-garonne
c'est une compte j'ai testé pour vous
les yaourts aux fruits sans colorant il
y en a quand même un peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle annette
j'ai 29 ans je sais pas conduire je fais
pas très bien ma cuisine je n'aime ni
lire ni aller au cinéma
alors attention je suis une bande de
sexualité de sensualité et de mélanger
je t'attends toi l'homme qui sera mon
détonateur je demande même pas de photo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était pendant l'horreur d'une profonde
nuit
ma mère jézabel devant moi c'est montrer
comme mon jour de sa mort pompeusement
part et par là les malheurs n'avait
pointe a battu sa fierté même elle avait
encore cet éclat emprunter dont elle eu
soin de peindre et donné son visage pour
réparer des ans l'irréparable outrage
toi m'at-elle dit filles dignes de moi
le cruel dieu des juifs l'emportent
aussi sur toi maman mais tu me dis que
pour me tabasser
google est elle est partie la méchante
elle est partie par la fois ci c'est
allé cueillir sa juste colère a voulu
que je frappe alors qu'elle est atteint
non c'est pas m
c'est la méche en quoi vous frappez la
fise alors que cela perd en ciel un cas
l'erreur
il a rattrapé j'espère puisque
apparemment elle est partie par là
bon alors si je comprends bien monsieur
le duc de saxe cobourg pour vous on peut
carrément parler d' événement théâtral
de la saison absolument jamais et je
crois que jamais guignols n'a été aussi
loin dans d'en atteindre cette
adaptation de leur pire récession
sinon je veux bien je veux bien en fait
puisqu'on parle du travail de le grumier
parlons-en
c'est quand même très confus tout ça un
exemple au troisième acte est bien quand
jézabel sorte par là et ben moi
j'entends des gens comme ça qu'ils
n'étaient pas passés par là alors que
les entrées sorties l'a d'ailleurs moi
même j'étais au bout d'un moment je les
dis jusque là elle est sortie par là je
me dis je le dise
cela
[Musique]
m
papa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le prix léon mort visart destiné à
récompenser un admirateur de l'oeuvre de
les hommes envisagent a été décerné
comme chaque année à lyon on vise à
maisons-laffitte émouvantes obsèques
clients matin maisons laffitte de
l'éleveur de chevaux henry père chine le
corbillard été tirée par trois purs
sangs caparaçonnés de crêpe noir premier
le 12 18 3 2e le 5 place yves du manoir
troisième 6 hermione devant la menace
d'un déclenchement désormais imminent de
la troisième guerre mondiale
la traditionnelle foire aux jupons de
molinard sur la clope a été reporté au
16 août lors de la cérémonie d'ouverture
des jeux olympiques c'est le français
alain chabot qui portait la
traditionnelle flamme olympique
il a été transporté dans un état
désespéré à l'hôpital des grands brûlés
météo après dissipation des brumes
matinales le temps sera beau et chaud
sur l'ensemble ricardo montasser ses
rythmes cubains depuis que des critiques
aïe aïe aïe
aujourd'hui comment séparer d'eux devra
jours il est très important de bien
savoir séparer d'oeuvre dino bien
séparer de vrais jumeaux
c'est la seule vraie différence entre
l'homme et la bête il faut jamais invité
deux vrais jumeaux un dîner mondain un
seul suffira largement de toute façon
comme ça il mangera deux fois moins et
puis il dira deux fois moins de
banalités qui on avait invité son frère
vu qu'ils sont rigoureusement identiques
j'ai ici deux jours dans un premier
temps nous allons vérifier qu'il s'agit
de vrais dim aux deux genoux doivent
évidemment se ressembler trait pour
trait or que voyons nous nous voyons que
parmi ces deux jumeaux l'un des deux au
moins celui-ci ne ressemble pas du tout
à l'eau c'est donc un faux document
ok je suis un faux jumeaux la honte
m'envahir
[Applaudissements]
voici maintenant un vrai jour
[Musique]
et voici deux oreilles deux vrais
jumeaux dit monozygotes c'est à dire ils
sont tout-à-fait inséparables
nous sommes inséparables dans l'état
actuel de la recherche
nous savons que si l'un des deux vrais
jumeaux subi une douleur physique son
frère ressentira exactement la même
douleur et exactement au même existe un
moyen terrible de séparer devrait jouer
et l'or je demanderai à mme jeannine
jeanine le coulis qu'habite 14 rue
nationale
villeneuve saint georges dans le 93 le
poids de bien vouloir cesser de touiller
sa mayonnaise lorsque je m'exprime c'est
extrêmement perturbant d'autant qu'il
s'agit d'une expérience très difficile à
réaliser
merci moi je disais donc il existait un
moyen très très pénibles pour séparer
deux vrais jumeaux mais regardez donc à
louis il sait pas jouer au poker
elle est pour vous j'arrive
je suis seul ce soir avec mes rennes
plus qu'une seule fois
[Musique]
non d'un prochain entretien nous verrons
ensemble comment séparer les blancs
désunis
[Musique]
j'échangerais bien ma vie morne et
plates contre un amour à l'épreuve du
temps j'échangerais bien la banalité qui
m'entourent contre un amour vrai
j'échangerais bien ma solitude contre un
bonheur à deux et j'échangerais bien aux
cimes mon poste de radio contre une
sacoche pour mon vélo moteur oui c'est
un transistor un appareil à piles
mais on peut aussi le brancher sur le
secteur là là on peut le brancher
lausanne
l'historien elle est hyper le vin est
formel davy crockett des pas mort devant
soi l'amour que l'on croyait
généralement mais derrière c'est tout
non elle voudrait faire une grimace
oui je veux bien merci
et
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
leurs maris
[Musique]
et